or him oh good afternoon everyone thank
you for being so patient and for being
here I'd like to begin by thanking again
not and the Austrian presidency I'd like
to wish them all the best but I'd also
like to thank them for having given us
the opportunity at the beginning of
their presidency to have a general
affairs council meeting it was a long
meeting a very intense meeting but a
very useful one for both my team and
myself everyone had the opportunity to
share their analysis their ideas to put
questions I often say ladies and
gentlemen that the unity of the 27 that
care not just referred to unity that was
confirmed today isn't a god-given it's a
unity that is achieved by listening to
each other by listening to the
institutions of the European Parliament
as well as the council and for my team
and myself there is a degree of
transparency and objectivity that we are
going to continue applying listening to
each and every member state so thank you
very much Austrian presidency and
Gannett for having taken this initiative
and as I said I'd like to wish you all
the best for the Austrian presidency
because you're taking over the
presidency at a key moment because it is
during the Austrian presidency that we
will have to reach an agreement on this
negotiations with the UK agreement on
the withdrawal agreement as well as the
political declaration there are 13 weeks
left
aim at the moment our main aim is to
continue and conclude on the withdrawal
agreement as you know what is in green
is agreed so 8% has already been agreed
with the British and then in parallel to
this we also once we finalize this
agreement need to work with the
UK to come up with a joint political
declaration on the future relationship
now this morning as cannot requested I
shared our analysis with the 27
ministers this at the end of a new week
of negotiations and in the light of the
discussions that we had yesterday with a
new brexit Minister Dominic Raab I had a
very useful and very cordial meeting
with him yesterday
and as you know a few days ago we
received the UK's white paper on the
future relationship and as you know this
white paper is the result of a very
intense internal debate in the United
Kingdom a debate that was necessary and
I think we've all seen that this debate
in the UK is not over yet as I said to
the ministers there are several elements
in this white paper that does open the
way to a constructive discussion leading
to the political declaration on our
future relationship
let me quote a few of the positive
elements the proposal for a free trade
agreement which will be at the very
heart of our future economic relations
now basically we have a key proposal
there that this was part of the
commission council guy guidelines namely
that we need an ambitious free-trade
agreement the second element commitments
to a level playing field especially as
regards state aid and the rules on
employment and environment and thirdly a
broad convergence on the need when in
fact the absolute need to cooperate on
both internal and external security and
on this point what is actually very
importantly positive in the UK white
paper is the guarantees that are going
to be provided for defending fundamental
rights and the recognition of the role
to be played by the European Court of
Justice as sole arbiter why is that
important
because this breakthrough with the
support of the UK and the European Court
of Human Rights means that the exchange
of data will be made easier between the
UK and us whilst protecting the
fundamental rights of citizens so this
opens up the possibility of us extending
our offer on internal security
cooperation in particular as to the
future economic partnership er the white
paper has raised three series of issues
which I put forth and we we have
questions that so we have put to the UK
and we await answers firstly the white
paper proposals we need to see if they
are compatible with the principles set
out by the 27 Heads of Government and
state at the European Council meeting in
March in fact even before March when the
negotiations began in June 2016 these
are principles that were reiterated by
the foreign ministers today integrity of
the single market in the customs union
the indivisibility of the four freedoms
and the respect of the autonomy of the
EU decision-making decision-making of
the 27 member states these are three key
elements that were in the Mandate of the
European Council in my mandate and I
will be scrupulously respecting them
right through to the end of course our
main aim is to protect the EU single
market to protect what we are at this
moment in time let me give you one
example the UK says that they are
willing to align itself on the EU
standards for goods but only for goods
that are checked at the border the UK
consequently would not align itself to
our agro-food rules as regards GMOs or
pesticides because the respect of these
rules is not checked at the border and
this was in fact confirmed to us this
week in the
ago she Asians so how can we protect
consumers in Europe we have a duty of
care to protect consumers in the single
market and on which basis could we
accept the free circulation of goods so
that is a question that we have put to
the UK a second question are these white
paper proposals workable are they
applicable without any additional
complex complexity or additional
bureaucracy for example the regulatory
alignment on goods and furthermore on
what the facilitated customs
arrangements as proposed by the UK as
you will have seen these proposals would
mean to terrorists would be applied
either the UK tariffs or the Union arif
tariff or goods that are going to go to
the UK market or whether they are to go
to the European market there
respectively so this creates practical
problems for example how can the customs
services verify that final destination
of the goods such to choose the correct
tariff so as to ensure that they apply
the correct tariff err is there not a
major risk of fraud what would be the
financial and administrative extra costs
B for businesses given this new a dual
system now brexit cannot and will not
justify additional bureaucracy what
would the impact be if the UK has
tariffs lower than the EU tariffs
what impact would it have on the
finances of the Member States and such a
complex system would also raise a much
more fundamental question how could the
EU delegate the application of EU
tariffs to a country that is no longer a
member state that is no sudden no longer
subject to our rules of governance
and is it possible is it legally
feasible and then a third set of
questions we put to the UK are the
British proposals in the interests of
the EU as we said our aim is to protect
the interests of the EU in these
negotiations well by definition the
common rule book for goods would not
only cover services because the UK wants
to be free to diverge on the rules for
services now as you know in any product
that we have take this your your
telephone between 20 and 40 percent of
the value of this good is linked to
services so how will we avoid unfair
competition via the services because the
UK would be free to diverge on the
services so how can we avoid unfair
competition as a V EU companies how
could an autonomous British trade
independence be feasible how can we
allow that how can we avoid UK companies
having a significant competitive edge
with a V the EU companies so these are
the sort of questions that I put to the
UK delegation today with the mini crap
and we will continue this discussion and
look constructively constructively at
the answers we will get to our questions
but our main focus must be and will be
the finalization of the withdraw
agreement let me recall that the
withdraw agreement is the pre requisite
the prerequisite for an orderly
withdrawal also for the transition
period and for creating the trust that
we need the trust that we need to build
a solid partnership for the future this
this requires in particular as you
mentioned cannot legally operative
backstop an all-weather insurance policy
to address the issues of Ireland and
Northern Ireland and all twenty several
member states insist on this why because
we are committed to protecting Ireland
and Northern Ireland against the
consequences of brexit and to preserve
the Good Friday Agreement in all its
dimensions I said this on my last visit
in Ireland the nose on Island a few
weeks ago we're engaged with
stakeholders across both communities
both communities let me simply recall
the commitment taken by Prime Minister
Theresa May to add a backstop in a
letter to President to skin March and
the respect of this commitment is
essential and I made clear yesterday to
the mini crab that we are not asking we
are not asking for a border between us
and Ireland and the rest of the UK but
we need is checks on good checks and
good because the UK wants to leave the
single market the customs union and our
common commercial policy we cannot
afford to lose time on this issue and
this is why we have invited UK to work
on the backstop next week we are open to
any solutions any solutions as long as
they are workable and can be transformed
into a legally operative text in time
for the withdraw agreement it is a drone
even if you want to reach deal it is
also our responsibility to be prepared
for all scenarios including a new deal
the European Council said we have to
step a preparation at all levels for all
scenarios and the communication adopted
yesterday by the Commission should be
read in this
context we are encouraging national
administration's and companies to use
the time we have which is short very
short to accelerate this preparation
final more because I will show you the
wall finally ladies and gentlemen we
need to find an agreement on all the
outstanding issues and the withdrawal
agreement this of course includes the
issue of Ireland and Northern Ireland
that's most serious issue but also the
British military bases in Cyprus and
obviously Gibraltar now each of these
issues is important and we need to have
an agreement on each and every one of
these issues agreement on them is
necessary prior to us adopting a
withdrawal agreement they are necessary
with the UK we need to also draw up the
joint political declaration on our
future relationship this by October now
at this stage in the negotiations we
don't have many weeks left but it's
actually it's not a matter of needing
more time it's a matter of choosing the
right decisions and being absolutely
clear because after all we are creating
an international legal treaty so we need
legal certainty and a legal clarity so
the earlier we can achieve this
certainty and clarity the earlier we can
start discussions on our future
partnership we want this to be as
ambitious as possible not only on trade
and on the economic front but on other
areas of common interest and also so
that we can have a strategic partnership
that would have an internal security
aspect to it as well as a foreign policy
in